[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's an early morning in may
and for 1.6 billion muslims around the
world
now is also the holy month of ramadan
marked by 30 days of fasting from
sunrise to sunset evenings are spent
together with family over a breakfast
meal called iflat
we followed five women
in five countries
as they prepare for this evening
[Music]
the day begins at 10
[Music]
my name is nancy hawk and i live in
pleasanton california
i'll be making a traditional bangladeshi
we'll have boot which is garbanzo beans
also hot petas which is meat stuffed in
puff pastry and also making some shrimp
curry because my boys love it with some
paratha
it's not hard to cook actually if i
think about it i probably cook the most
during ramadan for some reason maybe
because i'm not eating and i'm so
excited by a star
that i i want to make a lot of different
types of dishes for my family and eat
together
this excitement is echoed
kitchen to kitchen
family to family
[Music]
vacancy
[Music]
but in syria the sentiment is
[Music]
[Music]
overall there is a sense of solidarity
between the women in the kitchen amongst
the frenzy of chopping and boiling this
is their domain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
national
[Music]
foreign
i learned to cook these dishes from my
mom my mother-in-law and my
sister-in-law each of them have their
own take of recipes that they choose
from
my sister-in-law is really good with
shortcuts my mother-in-law has a lot of
traditional recipes and my mom has the
recipes that she made when i was growing
up so i like to just pull from each of
them
as the day progresses the effects of the
fast begin to settle
[Music]
harmony
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ascent it approaches and the time for
the call to prayer nears preparations
for the aflar come to a head raiden i
want you to put a white plate on each
mat
ramadan is not just about fasting it's
about cleansing yourself
[Music]
and so the 30 days it forces you to
reflect and think about all of that
and because everyone's doing it together
with your family or your extended family
it's a way to reinforce that and see how
can you be better
and then everything stops
around the world echoing across
landscapes is
the fourth cult of prayer of the day
[Music]
with dates and water at the ready it's
time to break their
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ramadan is a really special month the
whole muslim community is a part of it
and it's really special to know that
we're all breaking fast together no
matter where we are it might be often
timing a little bit but this is one of
the few days where we actually sit
around the table and we eat together
which is really heartwarming
[Music]
hi my name is beryl sharachewski i
produce the ramadan around the world
series it took 10 filmmakers to bring
this project to life there are five
other stories the link is below in the
comments if you want to check them out
and over on our youtube community page
we have a q a with the filmmakers i hope
you like it